Thomas and Friends is celebrating 75
years and to help those celebrations
we've created an episode called Thomas
and the Royal engine is about Sir Topham
Hatt and Thomas embarking on a journey
to London to visit the coin and to make
it even more special we brought in some
great cast and none other than Rosamund
Pike to play the role of Duchess oh how
rude of me I should introduce myself my
name is Duchess Duchess of Loughborough
Duchess has a very very important job in
that she transports the royal family
which is obviously a very exciting job
and but comes with great responsibility
and you don't really want anything to go
wrong when you have very important
passengers she's a brave little engine
she's lovely she's charming she can't
seem a little rude times but it's only
because of her sort of anxiety actually
she's a very very warm friendly engine
who's looking for friends and we are
delighted Harry the Duke of Sussex is
introducing this very special episode
this year Thomas and Friends is
celebrating 75 years of friendship and
teamwork the story starts late one
afternoon on the Island of Sodor
I think this is a very beautiful and a
pisode for the 75th anniversary it's got
all the key characters and some new ones
and some unexpected ones and I think it
puts Thomas sort of front and center
giving him a very noble and important
challenge and he emerges from it
triumphant
[Music]